that was ten years ago the 2009 season
capped with Super Bowl 44 in Miami
somehow Drew Brees and the Saints
stunned the Colts that was a game where
the Colts were favored by a fairly
significant margin to win the game that
had the onside kick the surprise on
concede kick to start the third quarter
but Brees and the Saints held it
together got the win and that's the only
time Brees has been to the Super Bowl
so clearly the only Super Bowl he's won
almost got back last year what would
Chris if they could pull it back
together and it'd be very impressive if
they can pull it together after two
straight years of heartbreaking
postseason losses if they can get back
to the Super Bowl and win it what does
that mean to Brees legacy I think it
would be a big boost I think it would
make history kinder towards him you know
at least in the future when we look back
you know again Drew Brees is awesome we
know that you whether you want to debate
he's top five top 10 all-time either way
he's in that conversation we're talking
about him right
okay so cool so he's obviously there and
he's got all the numbers and he's always
gonna be looked at is that kind of that
numbers guy you know I almost say like
right now it's a little bit like Dan
Marino ish maybe not to that extent
because all we ever talk about with Dan
Marino's all we never won a Super Bowl
okay Dan Marino was awesome and he's a
Super Bowl winning quarterback the
Dolphins just never put a Super Bowl
team around him and I feel like that's
the same with Drew Brees in a lot of
these cases you know I think people
might look back and go oh gosh a lot of
yards and this but the only one one
Super Bowl how great was he he gets a
second Super Bowl I think that puts him
into a different stratosphere I mean
come on we know that's a very short list
of quarterbacks who have multiple Super
Bowl wins and that puts you in a rare
class and I think when you have that and
then the numbers to go along with it
multiple Super Bowl wins and you're at
the top of the list of all the passing
categories oh man then it's kind of hard
to start denying a guy that's oh he is
in the top five I mean he's a winner and
he did it this statistically and he was
consistent and all that so that's kind
of how I look at it how about you well
my loose recipe for quarterback
greatness and we talked about this in
relation to Donovan McNabb several weeks
back
statistics longevity dominance and
championships and Drew Brees has all of
us I mean he's playing into his 40s
something a lot of other great
quarterbacks
we're not able to do his statistics are
off the charts he's going to retire as
the leader in every major categories
only 20 touchdowns away from breaking
Peyton Manning's record he is dominant
as an offensive weapon although he's
never gotten the credit that I think he
deserves and he's got a championship
he's got one yeah give him a second one
crisp right look and he gets to Peyton's
got to yeah he's not gonna bump Peyton
in the estimation of the casual fan but
it could be the smart fan at that point
recognizes and admits that Brees was
better than Peyton Manning if Brees
could get a second Super Bowl ring well
that's right I think he injects himself
in that conversation right where I mean
we look at it okay let's just name the
quarterbacks multiple Super Bowl wins
right you got Brady with six Montana
with four Bradshaw with four Aikman with
three Manning with two other Manning
went to plunk it with two Bob Griese
with two Roger Staubach with two Big Ben
with two Elway with two Bart Starr with
two and that's where it ends okay
so you get there yes they'll since has
two well yeah but not really it's a de
facto - he really only has one as far as
playing but yes when you start to get
into that conversation with those
quarterbacks yeah you lump them in and
then you start to go okay well where
does he rank with all those quarterbacks
there that have multiple Super Bowl wins
and yeah I think it becomes a lot more
of a serious conversation with comparing
them guys like Aikman and Elway and
Peyton Manning and how you want to rank
him when he has you know another huge
marquee win on his stat sheet to go
along with it I think the one thing we
need to emphasize with Brees we talked
about it last segment he has overcome
years with horrendous defenses and it's
only recently that the defense has been
passable yeah right it was historically
bad for that stretch and and I think
another thing we need to point out and I
don't want to reel it again an old case
but that the the crap that was pulled
with the bounty scandal sure where the
NFL had a cultural problem something
that a lot of teams were doing right a
couple extra hundred bucks if you can
apply with a clean legal hit
incapacitation of your opponent and he's
off the field and you
knock him out of the game right now
there was a lot of teams doing that
there were a lot of coaches doing it
Gregg Williams who was the main culprit
had done it in other cities but the NFL
focused on one team one year and
hammered the Saints suspended Sean
Payton for the year suspended Gregg
Williams for the year that team fell
apart defensively and it took a long
time for it to get back together and
that took away some of the prime years
that Brees could have added a second or
even a third Super Bowl ring I don't
disagree with you there that's I I mean
I'm with you that messed up their mojo
as an organization and really set them
back two years you know maybe three it
really it confused a lot of things it
definitely did I mean it hurt the
personnel on the field of course it hurt
the coaching on the field without Sean
Payton and yeah they were kind of in a
run of a Superbowl Playoffs doing all
those things it looked like they were
gonna be a contender every year and that
happened and it really threw it all over
the place now I'll push back a little
bit you know hey there's been other
great quarterbacks with great with bad
defenses who still went you know to the
playoffs and things like that to me and
again I'm not trying to knock Drew Brees
I do think he gets a little bit of a
free pass there nobody wanted to hear it
when Peyton Manning's defense is stunk
we were all like well you should be the
number one seed how dare you you know I
did that to me wait wait wait wait when
did his defenses stay
where's offensively they were letting up
to 300 yards rushing John Elway played
on teams and the Broncos were the
defenses weren't all that special
there's plenty of teams where we can go
through it that way and look at it you
know Brady's played on some teams where
the defenses weren't that good they were
ranked somewhere between 20 and 32 so
I'm not trying to knock Drew Brees on
that but for whatever reason for me and
my money and maybe you're wrong I'm
wrong and you think I'm wrong and you
could tell me I'm an idiot after but I
do feel like he gets a little bit than
some quarterbacks
than others with that conversation and I
don't I just don't like when there's a
different set of standards from one guy
to knucks that's the the one that I did
I just feel like collectively Drew Brees
isn't appreciated and regarded the way
he should be historically and I do think
he's a top five God how can you retire
with every major passing record and not
be one of the top five guys in the
history of the game it's ludicrous that
there's that you
in between 8 and 12 all-time he's gonna
retire with every single you'll put Dan
O'Grady Peyton Manning Aaron Rodgers
Brett Favre as Sean Payton and all these
years doesn't matter well that's what
I'm telling you you did it with Andrew
Luck and Russell Wilson last week I'm
telling you their numbers would be every
bit as good or better and that's why I'm
not putting him in the top five with
those guys that's why I'm not but he's
the one who did it he's also new
achieved it but he had Sean Payton whose
great tip number nine coming next number
nine is really gonna make some people
mad can't wait I'll be right back
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports